In less than 20 days, Wimbledon will host the Olympic tennis tournament.
You would be 34 in Rio.
So is this the last time that you think you can realistically win an Olympic singles?
Yeah, this is gonna be my best chance I would think, particularly now winning Wimbledon just before.
Even though I was world number one in Athens and also in Beijing.
So I had a lot of heartbreak there as well, not coming through.
But I did get Olympic gold in doubles in Beijing, which was an amazing dream come true for me...
...and actually takes some pressure off this Olympics coming up now here at Wimbledon.
And actually as we speak, banners are going up behind us, you know.
And the Olympic spirit is already kicking in here.
So I'm very excited to be coming back. And I mean, Rio, who knows what's gonna happen?
Health will decide, family, there's so many moving parts here.
But this is obviously a big occasion and a big moment for tennis.